All right, Michael.
So the first thing that I want to delve
into is the notion of solution concepts.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Now, we've actually talked about
various solution concepts and
game theory one and game theory two but
we never actually, I don't think,
sort of explained what they were or
even pointed out that we were talking
about different solution concept.
>> So do we need to talk about
the concept of solution concepts?
>> That's right, we need to talk
about the concept of concepts
because it's concepts all the way down.
All right, so here's the basic idea.
A solution concept or really just
a concept is basically just a rule for
predicting how a game
is going to be played.
So the one that we spent the most time
on was Nash as a solution concept and
particularly Nash equilibrium.
And so in the notion in
the language of solution
concepts you're basically saying that
there's a rule there's a kind of
formal process by which some particular
game's going to be played and that is
you're going to play with the idea that
you're getting into a Nash equilibrium.
An equilibrium in general and
a Nash equilibrium in particular
because it doesn't makes sense.
So we talked about a few
others mention a few others so
we talked about Nash at length.
>> And
what made Nash a Nash was that that
all the players were playing in a way
that they couldn't unilaterally improve.
Right?
So they were
doing best responses to whatever
it was the other player was doing.
>> Right but actually that wasn't
really what made it Nash so much.
Well it was but the big emphasis
there is actually on equilibrium.
The idea is that you were
in an equilibrium because
it was in no individual's best interest
to move or to change in any way.
In the particular kind of equilibrium
we're talking about was Nash.
Okay.
So
in fact I want to talk about correlated
equilibrium because that's a different
kind of equilibrium,
that's still in equilibrium,
but is different from Nash and
in some ways turns out to be
better under certain circumstances and
I'm going to even argue that
in fact we use correlated equilibrium
all the time in real life.
I'll give you an example
of that at the end.
>> But it's correlated,
so related to Nash?
Yes it is and
in a very particular way and
I will tell you how in a moment,
awesome.
Okay so we're going to talk about
correlated equilibrium because that's
what I'm interested in but I shall point
out that there are several others.
There's trembling hand,
there's Stackelberg competitions.
There's subgame perfect.
We actually talked about subgame
perfect and when I say we I mean you.
>> RIght, in the context of
multi-stage game sequential games.
>> Right, game theory too.
But it's still a solution concept so
this notion of concepts and
solution concepts is not limited
to a simple Matrix Games but
actually all of these work whether
the games are repeated or not.
>> Okay.
>> There's also Bayes Nash we did not
talk about that.
Coco you mentioned Coco.
But I'm not going to talk about that and
there are a whole bunch of others and
they just kind of go on and on and on
and I think when I talk about correlated
equilibrium and explain how this
solution concept entire back in
you might see various other ways you
might come up with solution concepts.
I mean Trembling Hand sort of
scares me a little bit but
are we going to go into any
details about that in Stackelberg?
No I am not going to talk about this,
I'm not going to talk about this,
I'm not going to talk about this, and
I'm not going to talk about this.
And you know what I'm not
going to talk about this,
I'm going to talk about that,
sound fair?
Sounds like a segue.
>> Sounds like a segue.